ja jetzt dürfen sie begrüßen den
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland Olaf Scholz
der jetzt
kommt mit bertola
[Applaus]
ja herzlich willkommen Herr
Bundeskanzler zu unserem vierten
leserkongress etwas geringfügig später
als eigentlich geplant was dazu führt
dass wir hier eine
Mission Impossible haben wir haben
nämlich um den vollbesetzten Saal hier
nicht
warten zu lassen
freundlicherweise auf die Unterstützung
von Harald Schmidt zurückgegriffen der
wie unsere moderate Moderatorin
klauen gemacht hat und sie können sich
nicht vorstellen wie gut er das gemacht
hat doch
also ich bin mir nicht sicher ich meine
sie sind ja ein humorvoller Mensch und
gelegentlich schaffe ich auch ein
bisschen Ironie aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob wir das beide zusammen toppen
können
sicher nicht das
hängt ja alles von ihnen ab
wie das gar nicht anfangen also vor vier
Jahren war die damalige Frau
Bundeskanzlerin da die habe ich am
Schluss am Schluss ist mir glaube ich
gelungen ist ein bisschen Verlegenheit
zu bringen weil ich angedeutet habe dass
sie Herausgeberin werden könnte das hat
sie aber empört zurückgewiesen
also damit will ich jetzt nicht anfangen
dann nein aber noch mal ganz herzlichen
Dank dass Sie in einer Woche zu uns
gekommen sind an diesem Termin
festgehalten haben die indem sie viele
andere Termine haben verschieben müssen
mal schnell 30 Stunden zusätzlich in
einen engen Zeitplan zu quetschen das
ist ja keine Aufgabe die Leichen ja bei
mir gegeben das fertig zu kriegen eine
für heute zusammen kommen kann
das das wollte ich gerade sagen wenn sie
mir das Kompliment was ein Kompliment
erlauben sie schauen sie mich
ausgeschlafen aus
so
also sie haben sie haben schon ein paar
Stunden Schlaf nachholen können
die nachholen nicht ich glaube das ist
eine Illusion aber ich habe schlafen
können
aber sagen geht trotzdem 30 Stunden
Verhandlungen obwohl doch relativ viel
Vorarbeit geleistet worden ist auch von
Ihnen persönlich
das ist auch nicht die neue Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit oder
die Deutschland Geschwindigkeit soll ja
dabei rauskommen da geht es ja um
Leitung um Straßen um
Energienetze um
Eisenbahnlinien und vieles andere was
dazugehört und dafür brauchen wir mehr
Tempo wir sind ja doch ein Land das für
viele Jahrzehnte liebevoll Vorschriften
gebastelt hat die wenn man alles
zusammenlegt dazu führen dass wir
niemals fertig werden können mit all den
Plänen die wir haben wenn wir nicht
diese Vorschriften ändern und das haben
wir im letzten Jahr gemacht das machen
wir jetzt und da werden wir uns auch
noch viele viele Mühe geben vieles von
dem was dir Jahrzehnte über gewachsen
ist zu ändern damit das Deutschland
Tempo überall zustande kommt aber
dennoch es war doch es war doch
ausdrücklich Programmierer Koalition
also sich noch ganz gut verstanden haben
was ist alles nicht mehr geben soll also
keine Durchstiche rein auf gar keinen
Fall in der Nacht Sitzungen auch nicht
wechselseitige Beschimpfung das haben
wir jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen da
haben wir das volle Programm gehabt
sie haben ja auch mal gesagt wir von mir
Führung bestellt der bekommt sie hat
jetzt zuletzt keine Führung bei Ihnen
bestellt doch sie haben ja sogar die
Gelegenheit bekommen dass nachzulesen
ich glaube auf 16 Seiten was dabei
rausgekommen ist und das ist ja doch
etwas was an gar nicht so sehr erstaunen
muss dass viel zu diskutieren ist ich
habe eben schon über das gesprochen was
uns jahrzehntelang so Stück für Stück
zugewachsen ist aber ich will das gerne
ergänzen will stehen vor großen
Umbrüchen wir stehen auch vor
großartigen Wachstumsmöglichkeiten für
unser Land aber das alles gelingt nur
wenn wir die ganz unterschiedlichen
sorgen Fragen und Anforderungen die in
diesem Zusammenhang
zu betrachten sind schnell und zügig
zusammenführen und wer jetzt nichts
macht wer denkt alles geht so weiter wie
es die Jahrzehnte über war der kann sich
zurücklehnen und hat auch nicht viel
Gesprächsbedarf aber wenn man sich daran
macht dann wird schon überall verhandelt
über diese Fragen und das ist anders als
es in man schon mal war da liegen die
Lösungen nicht auf der auf der Hand das
ist nicht gesellschaftlich ausdiskutiert
und dann ist alles geklärt und man muss
einfach nur noch sagen wir machen das
jetzt so wie das alle sich denken
sondern in Wahrheit muss jetzt
stellvertretend und vor aller Augen
gesprochen und verhandelt werden wie wir
diesen großen Fortschritt in unserem
Land auch hinkriegen und das wollen wir
leisten und das ist meine Aufgabe dass
wir uns niemals dafür drücken und all
die Entscheidung treffen die notwendig
sind bevor wir zu dem Fortschritt auf
den einzelnen Fällen kommen wollen wir
würde ich gerne noch mal kurz bei der
Koalition bleiben
aus Kreisen der Grünen war zu hören es
gebe jetzt so etwas wie eine Achse sPD
FDP wie fühlen sie sich denn als
achsenmacht
ich finde
macht alles keinen Sinn all diese
verschiedenen Bewertungen zu
kommentieren tatsache ist dass wir
gemeinsam Ergebnisse erzielt haben die
sehr gut sind wir wollen das ja noch in
der Sache besprechen und wir unserem
Land weiterhelfen und das war die Mühe
wert und selbstverständlich ist es so
dass alle die über viele Jahre sich mit
den Fragen die wir da jetzt besprechen
und voranbringen sich beschäftigt haben
Vorstellungen haben was richtig ist aber
es ist auch richtig dass wir uns alle
einigen müssen als Gesellschaft als
Bundestag als Regierung damit das auch
tatsächlich stattfindet und da wird es
ab und zu sich die Einsicht durchsetzen
müssen dass die Sachen
nicht immer so sind wie man sie sich
selber denkt sondern das ist Kompromisse
gibt und für drei Koalitionsparteien
heißt das alle drei müssen und werden
immer wieder Kompromisse machen der
ehemalige österreichische Bundeskanzler
der heute morgen hier zu Gast war hat
überraschenderweise gesagt den idealen
Koalitionspartner gibt es nicht
würden sie den Satz unterschreiben
nein was ist ein idealer
Koalitionspartner also
das wäre ja aus der Sicht
der Partei die den idealen sucht einer
oder eine Koalitionspartner die immer
der gleichen Meinung ist das ist ja
nicht wahrscheinlich und insofern glaube
ich geht schon darum ob man eine
Koalition hat die sich auf die
Herausforderung unserer Zeit
konzentrieren will und nicht die Augen
verschließt vor all den Aufgaben die wir
haben und genau die haben wir
jedenfalls haben sie ihre beiden
Koalitionspartner jetzt auch
unterschiedlich zufrieden über das
Ergebnis geäußert
Herr Lindner war sehr sehr fröhlich wenn
man ihn darauf angesprochen hat und auch
getroffen hat seither die Grünen dagegen
haben sich doch sehr deutlich geäußert
in dem Sinne dass gerade auch was zum
Klimaschutz beschlossen worden ist das
reiche bei weitem nicht geht denn jetzt
der Streit in der Koalition weiter zu
diesem Thema nein wir haben sehr
abschließende Klärung gefunden über ganz
ganz viele Fragen die über viele Jahre
und ja nicht nur erst seit diesem diese
Regierung im Amt ist ungeklärt gewesen
sind oder nicht richtig geklärt waren
das haben wir jetzt geschafft und wir
haben auch vieles was an Umsetzung
Schritten in diesem
Koalitionsausschuss vereinbart wurde
schon weiter vorangebracht also nächste
Woche wird man sehen dass bei den
Gesetzen die wir zur Energieeffizienz
zur Gebäude Energie zur Frage des
bundesmissionsschutzgesetzes
voranbringen wollen auch schon Verbände
und interessierte Öffentlichkeit
beteiligt werden Ihre Meinung gefragt
wird und der Gesetzgebungsprozess
losgehen kann also das hat alles das
Tempo aufgenommen das ist aufnehmen
sollte als Ergebnis des langen
Koalitionsausschusses wir können ja
angesichts der Zeit die wir haben nicht
wirklich in die Einzelheiten auch das
klimapark haben die auf 16 Seiten
aufgeschrieben wurde darf ich das noch
sagen ich habe ja schon mal in einer
Koalition über Klima verhandelt und das
ging am frühen Nachmittag wenn ich das
richtig sehe los und ich glaube wir
haben so zwischen 13 und 14 Uhr am
nächsten Tag ohne Schlaf die Ergebnisse
verkündet dass das lange Verhandlungen
sind das war schon immer so und ist
nichts Neues der Blick in die
Vergangenheit verklärt ja aber ich
jedenfalls habe schon an vielen
Koalitionsausschuss Sitzung auch der
früheren Koalition teilgenommen bei
denen es über Tage ging und wo ist ob
wir Nächte ging und das wird wohl sich
nicht ganz aus der Welt schaffen lassen
ich würde annehmen dass einige hier im
Saal sind die zu Hause eine Öl- oder
Gasheizung haben und zu dem Punkt der
mich auch persönlich interessiert findet
sich in diesem Papier relativ wenig
Konkretes können Sie denn oder es gab
aber ja jede Menge Spekulationen die
insbesondere ihr Stellvertreter also der
Vizekanzler in die Welt gesetzt hat in
den letzten Wochen könnten sie denn uns
kurz klipp und klar erklären was auf die
Eigentümer von Gas und Ölheizungen in
neun Monaten zukommt nämlich im Januar
wir haben ja bestehende Regelung was den
Austausch betrifft die wir
weiterentwickeln werden aber das wird
alles sehr pragmatisch sein sehr
orientiert an den Handlungsmöglichkeiten
die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben und
niemand wird vor einer unlösbare Aufgabe
gestellt das haben wir uns alle
gemeinsam vorgenommen und ich habe es ja
eben schon gesagt wir haben
weitergearbeitet auch heute noch mal so
dass nächste Woche ganz konkret Texte da
sind wo wir dann auch noch mal die
Meinung von Experten und Experten dazu
hören ich glaube aber dass ich wenn das
veröffentlicht ist ich weiß nicht wann
das der Fall ist Montag oder Dienstag
die Aufregung schnell legen wird
also wir nehmen den Kanzler beim Wort
sie haben zu dem heizungsthema im
Bundestag vorgestern wörtlich gesagt ich
zitiere der Kanzler macht das ordentlich
und das wird funktionieren Zitat Ende
aber sie sind ja nicht der oberklempner
der Nation
also es ist sehr dankbar für die
Heizungsanlagen
okay ich rufe sie an ich Gott sei Dank
dass ich es nicht bin
sie wissen ja man kriegt heutzutage
einen einen Termin beim Chefarzt der
Universitätsklinik leichter als ein beim
Installateur während
Respekt für diese Arbeit war mein
Wahlkampf Slogan immer schon gehabt aber
es ist es ist ja wirklich so es fehlt
auch wie bei der Bundeswehr an allem ist
keine Wärmepumpen also sind sie nicht
vorrätig es gibt keine Solarzellen und
vor allem gibt es keine Installateure
die beides installieren sollen wo sollen
denn die und das so schnell herkommen
wie es eigentlich herkommen müsste damit
damit wir unsere Ziele bei der
Energiewende erreichen können
zunächst mal gibt es ja sehr viele
Installateure in der Tat gibt es eine
große Nachfrage die auch viele
hunderttausende Heizungen regelmäßig
installieren jetzt eben andere aber das
ist ja jetzt etwas was vorhanden ist
trotzdem
weisen sie auf ein Thema hin dass uns
alle umtreiben muss nämlich wie kriegen
wir das wirklich hin dass all die Sachen
passieren die wir uns vorgenommen haben
deshalb habe ich dafür gesorgt dass wir
bei der Klausur des Kabinetts in
Meseberg und mit Wissenschaftlern
unterhalten über die Frage was ist alles
notwendig wir werden das auch in dem
unseren eigenen Strukturen der
Bundesregierung noch mal mit vielen
anderen erörtern und da kommt schon auf
unser Land was zu also wenn wir all die
offshore Windanlagen die
onschow-wind-anlagen die da
Energieanlagen installieren wollen wenn
wir das Stromnetz so ausbauen wollen das
ist die riesigen Mengen Energie
transportieren kann und das alles bis
2030 so hinkriegen wollen dass 80
Prozent des Stroms auseinander waren der
Beginn stammt wenn wir gleichzeitig
hinkriegen wollen
dass das dann wird es Gesetzesänderung
und mehr Fachkräfte geben müssen und
Milliarden schwere privatwirtschaftliche
Investitionen zum Beispiel in Offshore
Windparks wobei das nicht so schwierig
ist weil das Geld
sucht sich die Anlage schon die sind
alle verzweifelt hinterher wie sie das
endlich hinkriegen können eine sichere
gute Geldanlage in Deutschland zu finden
mit solchen Investitionen und darum
werden wir das auch bewerkstelligen und
was Fachkräfte betrifft haben wir uns
ausgerechnet ausrechnen lassen das ist
die eine Rechnung dass wir über alles
hinweg und über alle
qualifikationsstufenweise auch von
angelernten Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern
von Meistern von Ingenieuren und
Ingenieuren und so weiter und so fort
etwa 700.000 Fachkräfte im Laufe des
Jahrzehnts zusätzlich brauchen das passt
aber ganz gut zu der sowieso von uns
angestrengten Fachkräfte Offensive und
zu den Gesetzen die wir jetzt gerade
machen über die Erleichterung der
Zuwanderung von Fachkräften aus aller
Welt damit der Wirtschaftsaufschwung in
Deutschland stattfinden kann wie schon
mal in den 50er und 60er Jahren und
genau das ist worauf wir jetzt zustreben
ein großer Wirtschaftsaufschwung mit
unglaublich wir Investitionen in die
Zukunft die Investitionen werden ja aber
nicht nur vom Privatunternehmen und und
Privatleuten getätigt werden können
sondern wirklich gibt es eine enormen
Finanzbedarf den den in der Stadt
befriedigen muss
also wo kommt das Geld dafür her in dem
Koalitionsausschuss ging es ja nicht um
die um die um die Mittel auch für die
soziale Abfederung die auch der SPD sehr
wichtig ist der Finanzminister hat die
hat die Eckwerte für den Haushalt 2024
ja immer noch nicht vorgelegt
wir haben da sind jetzt kommen jetzt
viele Dinge zusammen erstmal wir sind
jetzt haben auch schon diskutiert wie
die soziale Abfederung oder die
Unterstützung von Investitionen von
Bürgern und Bürgern in ihrer
Heizungsanlagen vorangehen kann da wo
das notwendig ist übrigens vor allem im
Bereichen wo gar keiner gezwungen ist
sondern der Heizungsanlage auszutauschen
sondern das gerne macht und deshalb war
der Mitteln Anspruch nimmt wie wir sie
jetzt ja auch schon haben für solche
Fälle da haben wir jetzt verschiedene
Punkte zusammengetragen und werden
versuchen im Laufe der nächsten oder
übernächsten Woche auch ein ganz
konkretes Förderkonzept das passt zu dem
jetzt gefunden im gesetzgebungsentwurf
Entwickeln nur wenn wir über
Finanzmittel reden muss ich Ihnen
widersprechen der größte Teil der
Energiewende der größte Teil der
industriellen Wände in Deutschland sind
privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen
also
unsere Stromerzeugungsanlagen künftig
Windkraft
an Land und auf hoher See Solarenergie
Biomasse das was wir brauchen an
Wasserstoff ready Gaskraftwerken damit
wir 24 Stunden am Tag sieben Tage die
Woche immer genügend Strom haben für
alles was wirtschaftlich industriell und
privat erforderlich ist das sind alles
privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen
unser Stromnetz ist privatwirtschaftlich
unser digitales Netz ist
privatwirtschaftlich unsere Wärmenetze
sind weitgehend privatwirtschaftlich und
ich rechne jetzt die kommunalen
Unternehmen mal mit Privatwirtschaft ein
das sind alles große Investitionen die
stattfinden werden auch das
wasserstoffnetz für das wir jetzt den
Startschuss geben werden wird ein
wesentlichen privatwirtschaftliches sein
und wenn man sich mal anguckt was auf
den Kapitalmärkten in den letzten Jahren
stattgefunden hat dann ist es doch
offensichtlich dass es in der Welt
hunderte Milliarden gibt die gerne auch
in Deutschland investiert werden würden
privatwirtschaftlich aus Deutschland aus
anderen Ländern in diese große
Transformation die für unser Land so
notwendig ist und unsere Aufgabe ist
doch jetzt nur all die Kräfte zu
entfesseln damit wir auch ein bisschen
wieder mir Zuversicht und
Zukunftsoptimismus in unserem Land
entwickeln und nicht glauben die beste
Zeit lag schon hinter uns nein das ist
nicht meine Überzeugung wenn wir das
alles schaffen werden wir noch mal eine
Dynamik ein Aufschwung spüren wie das am
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts und in den 50er
60er Jahren beim sogenannten
Wirtschaftswunder der Fall war und das
ist jetzt möglich und darum geht's
zwei nein drei sozusagen Institutionen
die auch mal für Wirtschaftsaufschwung
in Deutschland verstanden werden in zwei
Wochen abgeschaltet damit die letzten
drei laufenden Atomkraftwerke ich nehme
mir andere daran dass ich nichts mehr
ändern wir hatten heute morgen auf
diesem Podium Frau Professor Grimm
Wirtschaftsweise Sachverständigenrat die
ja auch die Bundesregierung berät und
nochmal darauf hingewiesen hat auf
dieses Delta einerseits
brauchen wir auch für die wärmewende und
die anderen Dinge natürlich sehr viel
mehr Strom in den nächsten Jahren auf
der anderen Seite werden
Stromproduzenten wie zum Beispiel diese
Atomkraftwerke Kernkraftwerke
abgeschaltet
ist es so dass wenn es um Kernkraft geht
in Deutschland die die deutsche Politik
beratungsresistent ist
nein es hat eine Entscheidung gegeben
Anfang der 2000er Jahre dass wir Anfang
der 20er Jahre aus der Nutzung der
Kernenergie aussteigen
das haben dann einige nicht geglaubt
deshalb hat die Energiewirtschaft nicht
richtig in die alternativen investiert
das muss man glaube ich sagen weil viele
viel Kraft und Energie darin verwandt
haben dahin verwandt haben das
aufzuhalten das hat auch kurz geklappt
in der
schwarz-gelben Koalition und dann kam
das
Reaktorunglück in Fukushima und dann ist
auch dort die Entscheidung getroffen
endgültig auszusteigen also wir haben
zweimal entschieden dass die
Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden
müssen
Ministerpräsident Söder hat mit wenn ich
das dunkel erinnere als Umweltminister
von Bayern mit Rücktritt gedroht wenn
die Atomkraftwerke nicht abgeschaltet
werden sofort Herr Seehofer hat als
Ministerpräsident die Bundeskanzlerin
unter Druck gesetzt dass sie das sofort
machen muss und deshalb ist das eine
zweimal und sehr umfassend unterstützte
Entscheidung in Deutschland gewesen was
wir jetzt gemacht haben ist die Laufzeit
zu verlängern vom Ende des letzten
Jahres auf Anfang April nachdem ich mich
zusammen mit meinem Finanzminister und
meinem Wirtschaftsminister mit den
Unternehmen die diese Kraftwerke
betreiben unterhalten habe und geklärt
habe was die Bedingung sind und
eigentlich haben wir dabei
herausgefunden mit den vorhandenen Kern
bringen Stimmen kommen wir noch ungefähr
in April und so haben wir das gemacht
ich will dass sich ganz sicherlich Hans
Söder verteidigen aber die
die Entscheidung zum Ausstieg oder die
Entscheidungen letztlich auch von
verschiedenen Regierungen zum Ausstieg
aus der Kernkraft sind natürlich zu
Zeiten gefallen in denen ganz viele in
Deutschland gedacht haben das russische
Gaswerk ist billiges russisches Gas wird
es für immer geben und das ist ja nicht
mehr der Fall das ist nicht mehr der
Fall deshalb ist es ja auch so richtig
dass wir jetzt dafür sorgen dass wir
andere importinfrastrukturen haben und
denen nicht auf den Leinen geben gehen
die sagen na wo wir jetzt diesen Winter
hinter uns haben sollen wir den Ausbau
der import-infrastrukturen nicht weiter
vorantreiben wir brauchen all die
Möglichkeiten die Pipeline aus Norwegen
mit höherer importkapazität die
importmöglichkeiten über die
westeuropäischen Hilfen der Niederlande
Belgiens und Frankreichs mit ausgebauten
Leitungskapazitäten so dass mehr nach
Deutschland und wir sind ja auch ein
Transitland nach Europa gepumpt werden
kann und die ganzen zusätzlichen
Kapazitäten die wir in der an der
norddeutschen Küste haben wollen in
Wilhelmshaven in Stade in Brunsbüttel
und eben auch in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und wenn wir das
geschafft haben dann können wir vielen
Wechselfällen begegnen die uns bedrohen
und sind nicht mehr abhängig von dem
Wohlwollen eines einzelnen Lieferanten
das war sicherlich ein schwerer Fehler
dass man sich Alternativen nicht
geschaffen hat und wenn ich das
anekdotisch sagen darf ich war sehr
beeindruckt von meiner Reise nach
Belgien
wo ich ja in Seebrücke mir angeguckt
habe den dortigen Hafen und da kommt
alles zusammen eine Pipeline aus
Norwegen eine pipeland aus England das
ist LNG das wird nur dort dann
eingepumpt aus Dünkirchen Frankreich
auch LNG dass dahin gepumpt wird ein
eigenes lng-terminal und ein
Terminal wo man solche
regazifizierungsschiffe dranpacken kann
wie wir das jetzt auch schnell gemacht
haben alles gebaut als nichts los war
eine vollständige Überkapazität einfach
damit man Alternativen hat und das
hätten wir übrigens genauso wie dort
weitgehend privatwirtschaftlich auch
machen sollen dass wir Alternativen
haben zu importkapazitäten selbst wenn
sie nicht genutzt werden und diesen
Fehler dürfen wir nirgendwo wiederholen
eine
eine andere aber nicht weniger als
andere riesige aber nicht weniger
drängende Baustelle ist die Bundeswehr
sie haben für ihre
Zeitenwende Rede am 27 Februar letzten
Jahres im Bundestag stehenden Beifall
bekommen auch von Opposition jedenfalls
von CDU und CSU
doch wie jetzt auch die wir beauftragte
Frau Högl ihre Parteifreundin
festgestellt hat ist bis Ende letzten
Jahres von den 100 Milliarden jedenfalls
bei der Truppe bei der Bundeswehr noch
nichts angekommen nehmen wir nochmal das
Beispiel Panzerhaubitzen die Deutschland
an die Ukraine geliefert hat da ist
Ersatz für die für diese Haubitzen dann
bei der Bundeswehr erst knapp ein Jahr
nach dieser Lieferung bestellt worden
warum geht das so langsam
wir haben jetzt Sorge dafür getragen
dass geplant wird wie die Mittel
ausgegeben werden die der Bundeswehr zur
Verfügung stehen für langfristige
Investitionsentscheidung und das ist ja
nun mal so dass wir jetzt auch spüren
was für Fehlentscheidungen in der
Vergangenheit getroffen worden sind aus
Rechnungshof Ideen die für sich genommen
eine Klugheit hatten aus so einer
Berater Kultur die auch eine eigene
Klugheit hat hatten aber letztendlich
immer unterstellt haben es ist so Panzer
kaufen geht wie LKW von Daimler und
Volkswagen und man kaufen also man
bestellt und kriegt bald geliefert und
wenn Ersatzteile kaputt sind gibt es die
im Regal und kann man schnell reparieren
die Wahrheit ist die Dinger müssen
bestellt werden manchmal auch neu
entwickelt werden sie müssen die
Produktionslinie aufbauen weil die
letzte Produktion bei manchen dieser
Sachen schon viele Jahre zurückliegt und
dann ist die nicht aufrecht erhalten
worden welches privatwirtschaftliche
Unternehmen hält da so eine
Produktionslinie immer schön tip top in
der Hoffnung dass in 15 Jahren
vielleicht doch noch mal einen Auftrag
kommt wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel
entschieden das für den Flag Panzer
Gepard den wir zur Luft Verteidigung an
die Ukraine geliefert haben
Munition produziert wird weil es gar
keine munitionsproduktion in relevanter
Form mehr gab die wird jetzt im
Spätsommer zur Verfügung stehen die
Entscheidung haben wir lange getroffen
aber das dauert so lange wenn man da
keine Produktionslinie mehr hat und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt bestellen das
wird dieses Jahr wohl fast vollständig
erfolgen dass wir sagen dass das und das
dann wird das produziert die
Produktionslinie angeworfen damit es
größere Skalen Effekte gibt werden wir
unsere Freunde einladen dass Sie sich an
unseren Bestellungen beteiligen in der
Nachbarschaft das wird für die
Wirtschaft gut sein und für uns aber
auch
wir werden auch Dinge ändern müssen dass
wir langjährige Verträge abschließen
selbst wenn die Haushaltsplanung gar
nicht so lang ist muss man auch Verträge
die noch vielleicht in den 30er Jahren
laufen abschließen meine
Idealvorstellung ist wenn man paar
hundert Panzer hat und die halten 20
Jahre teilt man durch 20 und kriegt
jedes Jahr 21 und rüstet jedes Jahr 20
ein 20 ab dann läuft das sauber und das
gilt auch für Munition und andere Sachen
und wir werden Anzahlung machen müssen
damit das hinhaut sonst wird das auch
nicht wenn man alle diese Dinge
kombiniert dann werden wir eine
verteidigungswirtschaft haben die auch
unseren Sicherheitsinteressen laufen
dienen kann und wir merken ja was
passieren kann wenn ein wirklicher Krieg
zugange ist es wäre ja gut wir hätten
von allem was wir an Waffen haben und
was wir anderen zur Verfügung stellen
eine laufende Produktion auch was
Munition betrifft und wenn diese
Produktion im ein Schichtbetrieb läuft
kann man daraus in zwei Schicht und drei
Schichtbetrieb machen und im Sonnabend
und am Sonntag arbeiten also richtig
hochfahren weil das jetzt notwendig ist
aber wenn man nicht eine
Produktionslinie hat die im Einschicht
Betrieb existiert muss man erstmal eine
aufbauen und dass die Lage in der wir
sind und darum geht das nicht von einem
Tag auf dem anderen und entlarvt eben
auch viele Ideologien die in der
Vergangenheit über richtiges
Beschaffungswesen in Deutschland
gepflegt worden sind die müssen alle
geändert werden haben sie so lange an
ihre Verteidigungsministerin
festgehalten nein
also man kann ja sagen in dem Fall ist
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit erreicht
worden weil es glaube es kann gab vorher
keine die nur 13 Monate gedient hat
der
Vizeadmiral karg der maride Inspekteur
hat kürzlich bei uns im Interview in der
Zeitung gesagt ich zitiere wenn es
immerhin der Marine Inspekteur wenn es
nicht zu einem Anstieg des regulären
etas kommt war das Sondervermögen nur
eine palliativmaßnahme wir vertrauen
darauf dass die zwei Prozent kommen sie
sagten in ihrer schon erwähnten Rede vor
allem im Jahr Zitat wir werden von nun
an Jahr für Jahr knapp nein wir werden
von nun an ja für ja mehr als zwei
Prozent des Bruttosozialprodukt in
unsere Verteidigung investieren das war
es am 27 Februar
2022 in dem Jahr kamen wir auf 1,5
Prozent und so 1.23 also jetzt in diesem
Jahr sollen es 1,6 Prozent werden auch
da die Frage geht das nicht schneller
na ich könnte die Antwort dich eben
gegeben habe wiederholen da sie
ausführlich war erspare ich mir das es
sind jetzt die Bestellung zugange und
dann wird Stück für Stück geliefert und
das Sondervermögen schützt uns ja auch
vor einer
falschen Entscheidung von Politik unter
Druck die jetzt liefern muss dass wir
nämlich damit wir das Geld ausgeben
irgendwas kaufen was man sofort kriegen
kann obwohl wir die langfristigen
Investitionen auf den Weg bringen müssen
und das ist jetzt möglich dass wir die
langfristigen Entscheidung treffen aber
selbst wenn wir alles entschieden haben
welche Hubschrauber welche
Kampfflugzeuge was mit den Drohnen
passiert wie wir den Sky Shield zu
Verteidigung unseres Luftraums aufbauen
wie das ist mit welchen Panzern in
welcher Menge wie die Munition sein soll
wenn das alles passiert ist wird nicht
alles am nächsten Tag geliefert werden
können sondern teilweise werden die
Produktion dann angeschmissen und kommen
dann Stück für Stück zustande aber dann
dürfen wir und deshalb ist die Hoffnung
des
Herrn da ja auch völlig korrekt
dann dürfen wir nicht wieder aufhören
das steht ja auch bei dem
errichtungsgesetz zum Sondervermögen
drin dass wir jetzt uns an diesen zwei
Prozent im Schnitt der Jahre orientieren
und ich möchte auch dass die Bundeswehr
davon ausgeht dass die zwei Prozent Ziel
der NATO Grundlage ist für die
Investitionsentscheidung die Sie treffen
kann und auch für die Ausgaben die sie
jetzt planen kann wenn sie in das Jahr
28 und 34 und 38 denkt und das werde ich
auch sicherstellen dass wir einen Weg
finden das zu machen Haushaltsjahre sind
ja immer Jahr zu Jahr und eigentlich
kann man so langfristige Verbindlichkeit
mit der Art wie wir heute bei Haushalte
denken gar nicht eingehen aber man muss
ein Weg haben und deshalb habe ich dem
Verteidigungsminister auch gesagt
orientiert euch bei euren Planung daran
dass sie diese zwei Prozent immer zur
Verfügung haben will werde geht nicht
davon aus dass das in Frage gestellt
wird dann könnt ihr auch jetzt den Pfad
einschlagen und dann sind wir irgendwann
bei den zwei Prozent und werden das dann
auch über Jahrzehnte durchhalten
sie haben erklärt dass Deutschland auch
unter ihre Führung Führungsmacht in
Europa sein wolle und könne
könnten wir und zwar politisch wie auch
militärisch an die Stelle Amerikas
treten wenn sich beispielsweise ein
republikanischer Präsident weniger stark
für die Ukraine interessieren und
engagieren würde oder sich gar wie es
bei Trump ja auch gesehen wurde sich von
Europa und europäischen Sicherheit
abwenden würde
wir sind ein Land mit heute 84 Millionen
Einwohner
wahrscheinlich haben wir irgendwann im
Laufe dieses Jahrhunderts 90 Millionen
und das als die Statistiker uns falsch
vorher gesagt haben sind ja jetzt alle
der Meinung das können zu kommen wegen
unserer Wirtschaftskraft wegen unserer
Attraktivität wegen unserer
gesellschaftlichen Offenheit darum
hatten sich übrigens in der
Vergangenheit auch immer alle verrechnet
weil sie die Freizügigkeit der
Europäischen Union nicht als
kalkülfaktor bedacht hatten sondern
immer nur die Linien der Vergangenheit
nach vorne gerechnet haben und
wir werden das große Land mit der großen
Bevölkerung mitten im Zentrum der
europäischen Union sein aber wir sind um
es mit Helmut Schmidt zu sagen trotzdem
eine Mittelmacht also die USA geben für
Verteidigung 800 Milliarden Dollar aus
ich glaube die Staaten der Europäischen
Union sind irgendwo zwischen 300 und 400
Milliarden habe ich jetzt nicht genau im
Kopf aber etwa in der Größenordnung da
kann man sich vorstellen selbst wenn wir
dann alle zwei Prozent haben und ist
dadurch ein paar substanziell Mehrwert
an die Größenordnung kommen wir als
eu-wahrscheinlich nicht ran trotzdem ist
das viel und rechnerisch sogar mehr als
was Russland für seine Verteidigung oder
seine Beteiligung kann ja nicht sagen
seine angriffsideen ausgibt und deshalb
ist das natürlich etwas was uns auch
eigene Sicherheit schaffen kann aber ich
bin Transatlantiker und ich möchte alles
dafür tun dass die gute Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Europa und den USA zwischen
Deutschland und den USA erhalten bleibt
und ich bin sehr froh dass wir mit Joe
beiden einen richtigen Transatlantiker
als Präsidenten der USA haben das hat
die Beziehung zwischen uns allen
wesentlich verbessert und wir werden
unseren Beitrag für gute Beziehungen
leisten
was macht Deutschland wenn nicht Donald
Trump die Ausnahme in einer Reihe von
transatlantischen Präsidenten gewesen
ist sondern zusammen beiden vielleicht
der letzte Transatlantiker als
amerikanische Präsident gewesen ist naja
ich
zunächst mal als Staat als Regierung
arbeiten wir mit den Regierungen in
unseren Nachbarschaft und über in der
Welt zusammen die da sind getanzt wird
mit denen die im Saal sind das ist das
was man realerweise für die Politik hier
festhalten muss aber trotzdem darf ich
ja sagen dass ich das klare
transat-landische Bekenntnis des
amerikanischen Präsidenten sehr schätze
auch die persönliche das persönliche
vertrauen dass wir beide zueinander
entwickelt haben ich kann auch gerne
sagen dass ich bei allen Gesprächen mit
Abgeordneten aus beiden Häusern das
Kongresses
sowohl Republikaner als auch
deponokraten eigentlich ein Verständnis
entnommen habe das auch transatlantisch
ist
und nun weiß man ja nicht wie
amerikanische Wahlkämpfe sich auswirken
aber gegenwärtig ist das erstmal die
Ausgangslage und was ich aber nicht
vermissen will zu sagen
wenn wir den Blick auf den Zusammenhalt
der Gesellschaft verlieren wenn wir
nicht Respekt haben vor den
Lebensleistungen der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
und wenn wir
das im Hinblick auf Europa gesagt hat
aber es könnte man auf die USA sagen die
Zukunft
verloren haben in unseren
Vorstellungswelten dann darf man sich
nicht wundern dass Gesellschaften
dramatisch gespalten sind und Joe Biden
hat seine Art Wahlkampf zu machen der
spricht nicht von Respekt wie ich
sondern von mittelglas das ist aber
ungefähr das gleiche und meint auch die
gleichen Leute im amerikanischen
begriffsregime ist das auch
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter einschließend
gemeint und
das ist das was verloren gegangen ist in
unseren reichen Ländern des Westens
sonst könnten wir uns den Erfolg
rechtspopulistischer Parteien in Ländern
die von außen betrachtet keine Probleme
haben wie Norwegen Dänemark Schweden
Finnland Niederlande Deutschland
Österreich und nur diese zu nennen ja
nicht erklären oder den brexit nicht
oder den die Wahl von Trump von lauter
Leuten die nicht wussten bin ich
eigentlich oder einer wie ich noch Teil
der Zukunft meines Landes und das darf
nie vergessen werden in all den
politischen Auseinandersetzungen die
stattfinden dass man wenn man das aus
dem Blick verliert und wenn ein Teil der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger denkt es geht ja
nicht um mich das ist ganz schön schief
gehen kann weil aber Joe beiden in
dieser Frage
das Problem auch sieht habe ich die
Hoffnung dass er auch stiften kann dass
die amerikanische Gesellschaft
zusammenhält und deshalb auch ein guter
Partner bleibt
bei der Formulierung der Kriegsziele des
Westens im Blick auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine sind sie etwas
vorsichtiger zurückgreifender als andere
Politiker sie sprechen immer davon dass
Russland diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
dürfen und die Ukraine in nicht
verlieren dürfen andere sind wie gesagt
etwas
deutlicher im Sinne von Russland also
die Ukraine muss in gewinnen muss siegen
er könnten sie etwas klarer sagen was
damit gemeint ist also das Russland
nicht gewinnen darf und dass die Ukraine
nicht verlieren darf was soll das was
bedeutet das
der russische Präsident Russland haben
eine imperialistische Aggression
begonnen sie wollen sich einfach ein
Teil ihres Nachbarlandes oder sogar das
ganze Land an einverleiben und es sind
sehr identitäre Vorstellungen die das
begleiten wo dann lange
rumgeschwurbelt wird um am Ende zu sagen
eigentlich ist der
belarusse und der Ukrainer auch Russe
und daraus werden dann territoriale
Besitzansprüche abgeleitet und es wird
in irgendwelchen Geschichtsbüchern
geblättert wo Grenzen Mal waren und was
das dann bedeutet abgesehen davon dass
das auch sehr fragwürdige Konstruktion
und aus Ableitung aus der Geschichte
sind wo kämen wir eigentlich hin wenn
das die sicherheitsordnung in Europa
weiter bestimmen würde wenn wieder wie
im 17 18 19 Jahrhundert irgendwelche
historischen Ansprüche Anlass sind für
Kriege das war die große Errungenschaft
der gerade von Willy Brandt und Helmut
Schmidt vorangetriebenen
Entspannungspolitik der 70er Jahre dass
wir uns verständigt haben in der kscd in
der oscd in verschiedenen Dokumenten die
das wiedergegeben haben das mit Gewalt
keine Grenzen verschoben werden und
Deutschland hat das auch mit großer
Klarheit für sich gesagt dass wir unsere
Grenzen so akzeptieren wie sie sind und
das darf man auch von allen anderen
erwarten weil ansonsten ist der Friede
gefährdet
ich habe deshalb die Vorstellung dass
wir verhindern dass es ein diktatfrieden
gibt das einfach der Krieg eingefroren
wird wo er dann steht und dann praktisch
wenn auch nicht offiziell anerkannt von
weiten Teilen der Welt ein Teil des
ukrainischen Territoriums richtig
imperialistisch einverleibt worden ist
das heißt die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren das darf nicht passieren es
darf kein russischen diktatfrieden geben
und das heißt natürlich auch dass es
unvermeidbar so ist das Russland Truppen
zurückziehen muss
zurückziehen aus der ganzen Ukraine auch
von der Krim
wir werden
nicht für die Ukraine verhandeln wir
werden an der Seite der Ukraine unsere
Unterstützung zur Verfügung stellen und
deshalb bin ich nicht erfreut über die
ganzen Ratschläge die einige geben was
denn hinnehmbar ist und was nicht da
sollten wir uns sehr zurückhalten und
sollten vielmehr die Aussage tätigen die
jetzt erforderlich ist wir werden alles
dafür tun dass wir unsere Unterstützung
so lange aufrechterhalten können wie das
notwendig ist und das kann ja sein dass
das ein Krieg ist der dann eben zwei
drei oder vier Jahre dauert und das wird
dann uns alle noch gemeinsam sehr
herausfordern aber das ist glaube ich
das Beste was wir tun können zugunsten
der Ukraine statt ihr Ratschläge zu
geben was noch akzeptabel ist und was
nicht
der Krieg
der Krieg hat natürlich auch eine neue
Flüchtlingsbewegung ausgelöst inzwischen
sind
mehr Menschen
die wirklich vor allem Krieg fliehen
aber auch andere in Deutschland
angekommen als 2015
damals ihre Vorgängerin sagt ja damals
den berühmten Satz wir schaffen das
konnte man Zweifel haben dass das
wirklich geschafft worden ist jetzt ist
es jedenfalls so dass die die die Leute
die hier wirklich in der ersten Linie
stehen bei dem Versuch die Leute
aufzunehmen also die Flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen und auch auch zu integrieren
die schon sehr an ihre Grenzen gekommen
sind ich glaube sie wollen im Mai auch
noch mal mit den mit den Vertretern der
Kommunen sprechen aber schaffen wir es
diesmal auch nicht nur die Aufnahme
sondern auch die Integration
zunächst mal bin ich sehr dankbar für
die unglaubliche Hilfsbereitschaft
vieler Bürgerinnen und Bürger ein großer
Teil der Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine die
hierzulande Leben auf der ältere Frauen
mit Kindern ein paar Männer im
Erwachsenenalter aber die meisten sind
ja in der Ukraine und verteidigen ihr
Land dass das so gelungen ist mit so
viel Unterstützung das viele Bürger und
Bürger Ukraine aber sich zu Hause
aufgenommen haben das ist so viele
soziale Organisationen gibt so viel
ehrenamtliches Engagement die das das
möglich gemacht hat als Staat alleine
wäre das für uns glaube ich kaum
schaffbar gewesen aber mit dieser großen
Unterstützung klingt gelingt das ja bis
heute und trotzdem darf man die Augen
nicht verschließen vor den
Herausforderungen die damit verbunden
sind deshalb haben wir ja nicht nur
gesagt haben wir die
als Bund einen großen Teil der Kosten
übernommen die in dieser Hinsicht
anfallen und werden das auch weiter tun
und leisten alle Unterstützung um das
mal zu sagen wir haben letztes Jahr
3,5 Milliarden Euro gezahlt an die
Länder und
was weiterzugeben an die Gemeinden
einander haben es gemacht die anderen
nicht aber müssen interessanter Atlas in
Deutschland wäre viel an die Gemeinden
gegeben hat und wer nicht das ist nicht
ganz Konkurrent mit denjenigen die jetzt
was für die Gemeinden fordern sie haben
viel für sich einbehalten aber andere
waren auch wirklich so und haben viel
weitergegeben
und wir haben auch für dieses Jahr
wieder 2,75 Milliarden vorgesehen wir
haben entschieden dass wir die ganzen
Kosten für die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
dadurch dass die alle sofort
über die Sonderklausel der EU als
Flüchtlinge anerkannt sind übernehmen
und ihnen sie Ansprüche auf das
Bürgergeld haben
was übrigens damit verbunden ist dass
wir den großen Teil der
Unterbringungskosten tragen bis zu 75
Prozent was damit verbunden ist dass wir
Lebensunterhaltskosten tragen was damit
verbunden ist dass wir Weiterbildung und
Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen über die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit organisieren
damit möglichst viele davon schnell eine
Möglichkeit haben der Job Integration
das hat auch schon geklappt und soll
auch weitergehen wenn ich die Zahl der
Kurse betrachtet die dagegen fertig
belegt worden sind wir haben
Liegenschaften des Bundes
bereitgestellt ich glaube viele 10.000
Plätze und auch weitere
angeboten die gerne benutzt werden
können wir erheben dafür keine Miete und
haben auch einen großen Teil der
Errichtungskosten übernommen
wir haben im übrigen
die Möglichkeiten für Asylbewerber da
geht es dann kann nicht um die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge die mit ihren
Anliegen gescheitert sind sie
abzuschieben vereinfacht mit Gesetzen
die eine Beschleunigung des Verfahrens
vorgesehen haben auch das Asylverfahrens
das ist auch eine Leistung dieser
Regierung
und wir haben die eigentliche Lösung für
die Frage der Asyl der fluchtmigration
zum Programm der Regierung gemacht und
werden das jetzt ganz neu und zentral
umsetzen
denn das ist ja eine der Erfahrung die
wir in aller Welt machen
ob da nun so ein Trump auftritt oder
Viktor Orban und sonstige andere und
sagen hässliche Worte über Flüchtlinge
raus aus dem eigenen Land kriegen die
die im Wesentlichen
auch nicht wenn die Länder aus denen die
kommen die nicht zurücknehmen
das ist egal wie die Regierung sind auf
der Welt jetzt gibt es markige Auftritte
von markigen Politikern die marktige
Ankündigung machen und alle als
Bettvorleger enden in dieser Frage
und die einzige realistische Chance das
hinzukriegen ist dass wir mit Ländern
migrationspartnerschaften vereinbaren
wohl viele herkommen und auch mit
Transitländern und das wollen wir machen
das führt nämlich dazu dass und das
gelingt uns jetzt auch weil wir gerade
was zu bieten haben also gerade als
Deutschland wir brauchen damit wir
unsere Renten bezahlen können damit
unsere Wirtschaft wächst damit wir
unseren
ökonomische Bedeutung erhalten bis
Anfang der 30er Jahre etwa 7
millionenfachkräfte unterschiedlicher
Qualifikation für den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt das machen wir jetzt mit
unserem Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
und den Reformen leichter möglich und
werden es auch schaffen aus der EU aber
auch aus Ländern außerhalb der EU
und
wenn wir das aber machen dann kann ich
zu einem Land gehen und sagen eigentlich
brauche ich aus deinem Land ganz viele
gute Leute
und ich will mit dir gerne einen Deal
machen das davon so und so viel kommen
können wenn du mir gegenüber versprichst
dass alle die ich zurückschicke ohne
dass ihr das in Frage stellt von euch
als Staatsbürger anerkannt und auch in
Land aufgenommen werden
mit Indien haben wir es gemacht läuft
super
und wir wollen es mit weiteren Ländern
machen und wenn das dann überall läuft
dann haben wir auch eine Message die
sich in die Welt verbreitet die zwei
Botschaften beinhaltet erstens es gibt
für die vielen die sich für das Gute
Land Deutschland ihr Land der Hoffnung
interessieren eine reguläre Perspektive
wenn man hier gebraucht wird muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen eine Zuwanderung
nach Deutschland Zustande zu kriegen und
zweitens jeder Weg auf irreguläre Weise
nach Deutschland zu kommen wenn man gar
keinen asylanspruch hat keinen
Fluchtgrund hat der hierzulande
anerkannt wird ist
überflüssig vergeblich viel zu teuer und
viel zu gefährlich im Hinblick auf die
Tatsache dass ja wir wegen der
Vereinbarung mit den Herkunftsländern
die betreffenden wieder zurückschicken
können das wird nicht für jedes Land
gelten aber für so ziemlich alle und
deshalb ist das ein großer gamechanger
in der Migrationspolitik
und das was brauchen wir dann noch
Taten statt Worte also genügend
verwaltungsrechte und
Verwaltungsrichtern in den asylkammern
da freue ich mich auf die aktive Politik
der Länder
genügend
abschiebehaftplätze in den Ländern ich
bin begeistert über entsprechende
Entscheidungen die getroffen werden und
das ist dort niemals ein
kapazitätsmangel gibt wir brauchen
endlich nach zwei 14 15
die Digitalisierung der
Ausländerbehörden ich frage mich
wo leben wir eigentlich dass alle jetzt
diskutieren
wie war das 2014 und 15 und jetzt sind
wir fast zehn Jahre später und hören so
genau ermessen können wir das nicht
vielleicht ist ein Viertel der
Ausländerbehörden in Deutschland
digitalisiert das kann doch nicht wahr
sein
ich habe neulich jemanden gefragt der
auch so sagte was wäre ja alles tun
sollen gesagt ist deine Ausländerbehörde
digitalisiert es waren Landrat und
prominenter ich sage nicht mehr und
Teil die digitalisiert habe ich gesagt
vielleicht weniger Presseerklärung mehr
die Arbeit machen und das finde ich ist
schon etwas was man sich vorstellen kann
warum können wir elektronische Akten mit
dem es gibt sogar eher Ausländer heißt
das Prinzip nicht einfach von
Ausländerbehörde zu Ausländerbehörde
verschicken mir hat die mit mir
freundschaftlich verbundene
Verantwortlichen der Hamburger
Ausländerbehörde gesagt sie kriegen
Ausländer die aus anderen Gegenden
Deutschlands kommen
dann scannen Sie drei Aktenordner ein
dann ist das bei denen digitalisiert und
wenn die dann wieder in Hamburg
verlassen müssen sie das alles
ausdrucken weil die andere
Ausländerbehörde nicht in der Lage ist
dass digital zu empfangen im Jahre
2023 ich finde diese Arbeit muss gemacht
werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja Herr Bundeskanzler gelegentlich merkt
man ja doch dass ihnen
ihr am Spaß macht
ja das ist übrigens wirklich der Fall
trotz der Probleme will ich zum Schluss
bevor wir an den Saal übergeben
nochmal eine Frage stellen angesichts
dieser vielen Krisen Herausforderungen
Probleme wir haben ja ein paar davon
tangiert
haben Sie sich vielleicht irgendwann mal
in der schlaflosen Nacht dann doch bei
dem Gedanken ertappt wie schön ihr Leben
sein könnte wenn die cdu/c so bei der
Bundestagswahl zwei Prozentpunkte mehr
geholt hätte
nee
nicht eine Sekunde um ehrlich zu sein
und ich will das ja auch gerne
wiederholen und mit der jetzigen
Regierung weitermachen
ich habe es ja nicht anders erwartet
aber sie haben aber jetzt aber noch
nicht Herrn Söder dafür gedankt dass er
an ihrer Stelle im Wahlkampf sich an
Herrn Laschet abgearbeitet hat
[Applaus]
nein das habe ich nicht aber ich hatte
schon die Vorstellung dass es mir auch
egal sein muss und kann wer da nur
antritt weil ich glaube dass das was
wir und was ich vorzuschlagen hatte eine
gute Chance hatte wenn es darauf ankommt
nämlich tatsächlich die Wahl ist
genügend Unterstützung zu bekommen
das finde ich ist eine Einstellung die
einem kanzlerwürdig ist
vielen Dank so sie haben sich ja bereit
erklärt freundlicherweise hier Fragen zu
beantworten
[Applaus]
liegt in den Jahren so darf ich Sie
bitten wenn sie Fragen stellen wollen
aufzuzeigen sich mit ihrem Namen zu
nennen und auf das Mikrofon zu warten
bitteschön
ich sehe da einen Herrn
mein Name ist Oliver Sydow wir
bundesanze ich habe eine Frage so ganz
übergreifend sie haben davon gesprochen
dass wir Fachkräfte aus anderen Ländern
anwerben wollen Migration in welcher
Form auch immer
ist es mal zu Ende gedacht worden was
passiert denn wenn die guten Leute aus
anderen Ländern hierher kommen und diese
Länder dann weiter abfallen oder
absacken stärken wir denn da nicht
dadurch eher noch eine
illegale Migration oder einen eine
weitere Flucht aus diesen dann fail
States
also erstmal glaube ich ist das sehr
selten die reale Frage wenn ich jetzt in
Indien bin und mit dem Regierungschef
dort spreche mit dem wir eine
migrationspartnerschaft vereinbart haben
dann ist der hellauf begeistert weil die
haben wirklich sehr gute sehr gut
ausgebildete Frauen und Männer und
trotzdem ist das so dass die so viele
junge Leute haben das selbst bei einem
Wirtschaftswachstum das in Richtung zehn
Prozent ginge das nicht so einfach ist
dass alle entsprechend ihrer Fähigkeiten
und Qualifikationen eine Perspektive
finden würden und auch wenn ich jetzt
mit anderen spreche hat jetzt gerade das
Gespräch mit dem kenianischen
Präsidenten der hat gesagt er glaubt gar
nicht wie gut unsere Leute sind und die
sind arbeitswillig und würden das alle
gerne machen und das entspricht auch
unserem Wissen wenn ich das dazu sagen
will das heißt
in Afrika ist der größte Teil der
Bevölkerung unter 30 viele sind sehr
sehr sehr jung die werden unglaublich
Herausforderungen in vielen Ländern
haben
nicht nur alle Arbeitsplätze also für
alle an Arbeits- und
beschäftigungsperspektive zu finden und
das kann ja eine gute Partnerschaft von
uns allen sein es gibt das Phänomen auch
aber da muss ich sagen das Thema ist ja
schon losgegangen mit der Freizügigkeit
in der Europäischen Union das hat zwar
keiner gerechnet was da wohl bei
rauskommt aber die Wahrheit ist ja unser
ganzer wirtschaftlicher Aufschwung der
letzten 20 Jahre ist das Ergebnis der
Freizügigkeit in Europa und der Tatsache
dass wir ein Arbeitskräftemangel
entgegen aller Vorhersagen nicht
bekommen haben und jetzt wird es gerade
eng aber wenn wir uns Mühe geben können
wir das erneut vermeiden und das Land
sein dass seine kompletten
wachstums-perspektiven und
Wachstumsmöglichkeiten auch
ausreizen und tatsächlich nutzen kann
darum geht es ja bei dem was wir hier
machen es wird ja von den Ökonomen immer
geredet über das Produktionspotenzial
und wenn die dann pessimistisch über
Deutschland reden dann recht reden sie
eigentlich ja werden nicht genug
Arbeitskräfte haben deshalb reden sie
rechnen Sie uns runter wenn wir aber
Ihnen ein Schnäppchen schlagen und genug
Arbeitskräfte haben müssen sie uns
hochrechnen
hier vorne bitte
mein Name ist Fritz Müller Herr
Bundeskanzler ich habe eine ganz
einfache Frau wie oft kontaktieren Sie
ihre Vorgängerin
ich rede mit meiner Vorgänger und wir
treffen uns auch gelegentlich und
aber ich möchte wieder über Zeitpunkt
Uhrzeit und Häufigkeiten Auskunft geben
aber ich kann Ihnen gern versichern dass
Frau Merkel nicht über die Jahre eine
sehr gute ich würde sagen schon sehr
angenehme Zusammenarbeit Miteinander
entwickelt haben und die Tatsache dass
wir zwei Parteien waren hat unsere gute
enge freundschaftliche zusammenarbeiten
die behindert und warum sollte das nach
der Amtszeit plötzlich
[Applaus]
Andreas spinnerung
ich bin selbst in seiner Tür und
Heizungsbau
Meister und guter Mann heute
nicht mehr aktiv sondern im Jurastudium
mittlerweile
alles schlecht
dennoch frage ich mich aus meiner
persönlichen Erfahrung mit meinen
meisterkollegen und meinen ehemaligen
gesenkollegen weiß ich dass die meisten
nicht mehr Installateur und nach
heizungsbauermeister sind aus dem
Perspektiven dessen dass das die
baugenossen die Berufsgenossenschaften
und dergleichen nicht präventiv genug
Vorgehen gegen Arbeitsschutz gegen den
Bedingungen den der Handwerker
ausgesetzt ist und
langfristig gesehen ist das nicht
unbedingt der Beruf der Respekt und ja
mit gesundheitlichen Perspektiven auch
da ist wie wollen sie das schaffen dass
Leute wie ich nicht abwandern und
zukünftig neue kommen
na jetzt sollte ich ihn erstmal erzählen
wie das mit meinem Jurastudium so war
aber egal ich habe es gerne gemacht und
vor allem war ich noch viel lieber
Anwalt aber die
Antwort will ich ihn schon geben ich
glaube dass wir in der Tat für gute
Arbeitsbedingungen gute Löhne und auch
Sicherheit sorgen müssen und dass das
eine Rolle spielt genauso wie der das
Ansehen das bestimmte Berufe haben das
ist ja schon so dass das eine
Schwierigkeit ausmacht das gegenwärtig
nicht alles gleichwertig betrachtet wird
und das hat dann Konsequenzen für die
wir einen hohen Preis bezahlen weil
vielleicht junge Frauen und Männer für
die der Weg ins Handwerk eine große
Sache wäre sich deshalb dagegen
entscheiden
weil wenn ihr im Freundeskreis macht das
keiner oder man kennt auch niemanden
oder was weiß ich obwohl das eine tolle
Sache wäre die zu ganz vielen gut passen
würde und
wenn man jetzt guckt
und wir haben auch eine Form des
Sprechens entwickelt mit der ich sehr
hadere ich habe mich ja als
Sozialdemokrat seitdem ich mit 17 da
Mitglied geworden war immer eingesetzt
dafür dass das Bildungssystem
durchlässig ist dass man unabhängig vom
Elternhaus jede Möglichkeit hat die
besten
Ausbildungswege einzuschlagen
aber so wie manchmal geredet wird mit
dem Wort Aufstieg durch Bildung
klingt das dann für viele auch so als ob
sie was falsch machen wenn Sie sich
dafür entschieden Handwerker oder
Handwerkerin zu werden und das halte ich
für ein Fehler wir müssen also als
demokratische Gesellschaft die Respekt
gegenüber jedermann und jeder Frau hat
auch die unterschiedlichen
Lebensentscheidungen beruflichen Wege
die zufällig kommen die Gewalt kommen es
ist eben so gelaufen wie auch immer die
müssen wir es also respektieren und auch
als gleichrangig anerkennen neben den
Arbeitsbedingungen die sie sprechen und
in der Tat da gibt es was zu verbessern
und dem fühle ich mich auch sehr
verpflichtet schon deshalb weil das
biografisch bei mir dabei ist denn als
ich Anwalt war war ich dann irgendwann
Fachanwalt für Arbeitsrecht
[Applaus]
Franziska wandura mein Name ich wir sind
ja jetzt seit über einem Jahr mit dem
ukrainekrieg konfrontiert und meine
Frage ist auch wenn sie nicht besonders
elaboriert ausgedrückt ist aber können
wir als junge Menschen als breite
Bevölkerung irgendetwas tun oder sind
wir da auf die Regierung angewiesen und
können nur zuschauen
es tun ja ganz viele was und ich finde
sehr beeindruckend ich treffe überall
Frauen und Männer die irgendwas machen
auch viele hilfs-transporte in die
Ukraine organisiert haben und Güter
darüber gebracht haben in ganz
Deutschland begegnen mir ganz viele
Gruppen die genau das gemacht haben von
der Unterbringung habe ich schon
gesprochen und ich glaube das ist das
was man tun kann hier zu Lande und in
der Solidarität jeder und jede gemäß dem
was anliegt und wozu man sich aufgerufen
fühlt und welche Möglichkeiten man hat
und ansonsten sind wir ein
demokratisches Land in dem auch
diskutiert werden muss und das sind ja
alles schwierige Dinge viele haben Angst
vor der weiteren Entwicklung alle
älteren haben Kopfkino und erinnern sich
genau wie das war im Krieg mit den
ganzen Zerstörungen mit den vielen Toten
mit all dem was ihr Leben am Anfang
geprägt hat
und
viele Leute sind skeptisch ob wir zu
viel tun andere sind der Mann wir
könnten vielleicht noch mal was extra
machen und das muss ja in einer
Gesellschaft als Verständigungsprozess
gelingen dass man da nicht immer einer
Meinung ist aber doch so viel
beieinander dass man die Sachen
miteinander diskutieren kann ich glaube
so nach einem Jahr ist eingetreten dass
die meisten Bürger und Bürger mit dem
abgewogenen vorsichtigen Kurs der
Regierung sehr einverstanden sind und
zwar auch diejenigen die finden wir
machen sollten vielleicht weniger machen
sagen aber okay am Ende wegen die das
ordentlich ab und diejenigen die
vielleicht manchmal finden wir sollten
noch das eine oder das andere machen
sagen aber am Ende wegen die das
ordentlich ab und machen keine allein
Gänge und wenn man damit hilft das zu
diskutieren so dass man sich nicht in
Gegnerschaft sondern als gemeinsam als
Volk begegnet dass über die Frage
diskutiert was machen wir Angesicht zu
einer bedrohlichen Lage dann glaube ich
kann man auch ein Beitrag geleistet
[Applaus]
ja bitte
Simon Müller ist mein Name sie haben
über Digitalisierung geredet in den
Behörden das finde ich sehr gut
tatsächlich gibt es ja da auf
Landkreisebene noch viel Verbesserungen
und auf Bundesebene wurde das schon viel
gemacht als Mitarbeiter der Agentur für
Arbeit muss ich sie da sehr loben wir
sind sehr dickertalisiert
ich erlebe aber gerade dass zum Beispiel
wenn wir per E-Mail mit den Bürgern
kommunizieren müssen oder dürfen wir
keine personenbezogenen Daten mehr
versenden dürfen und das anscheinend
alle Behörden nicht mehr tun dürfen gibt
es da einen Plan das zum Beispiel wie in
anderen Ländern
der Bürger über eine App alle Behörden
erreichen kann denn wenn ich mit
Ukrainern geredet habe die waren sehr
verwundert wie viel wie rückständig
Deutschland ist im Vergleich zur Ukraine
ja
die Sache mit der E-Mail ist mir auch
untergekommen
ich habe die Anweisung gegeben ich werde
immer gucken wie schnell das geht dass
das geändert wird weil ich finde das
unverständlich das war ja während der
corona-krise ausgesetzt diese Regel und
es ist ja kein Unglück passiert aber
statt dass es dann einfach weiter bleibt
wir werden der corona-zeit ist es jetzt
wieder rückgängig gemacht worden als
sich das gehört habe bin ich aus allen
Wolken gefallen also das kann ich gar
nicht anders sagen und deshalb möchte
ich dass das so geändert wird dass ein
schneller zügiger Kontakt mit den
Bürgern und Bürgern möglich ist und das
zweite ist wir werden das mit der
Digitalisierung vorantreiben müssen und
müssen dabei auch ungewöhnliche Wege
gehen im Verhältnis zu dem was wir
bisher gemacht haben das ist mühselig
weil wir ein föderaler Staat sind mit
11.000 und etwas Gemeinden mit
400 und etwas Landkreisen und
kreisfreien Städten mit 16 Ländern
vielen Bundesministerium lauter
bundesober und Unterbehörden
und alle machen ihr eigenes Ding das ist
natürlich anders als anderswo dann einer
festsetzt wie es sein soll und mein
persönliches Gefühl ist wir brauchen da
jetzt mehr Fortschritt eine Stelle bei
der wir das unbedingt machen wollen ist
die Frage
der Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen
da wird es jetzt Schlag auf Schlag viele
Gesetze vom Bundesminister geben denn
wir müssen die Daten die wir haben
nutzen können ein großer Teil der
Medizinforschung die heute stattfindet
setzt Daten voraus und das jetzt
deutsche
hochleistungsfähige Medizingeräte
Hersteller wie man einer neulich gesagt
hat mit den Gesundheitsdaten der
Krankenhäuser von Mexiko City ihre
Geräte trainieren weil sie die Deutschen
nicht benutzen dürfen das ist ein
Anachronismus der schnell geändert
gehört
[Applaus]
Edgar Salzmann zunächst bevor ich die
Frage stellen würde ich mich einmal
gerne bedanken wollen ich finde sie
machen das toll man kann innerlich immer
streiten aber allein körperlich ist
alles durchzuhalten finde ich klasse die
Frage die ich kenne
naja sie kriegen eine Menge Kritik
insofern darf sie auch mal Lob sein die
Frage stellen möchte ist rund um die
Finanzmärkte wie schätzen Sie das ein
wenn wir da noch eine schwierige
Situation kommen oder so wie sie es
gesagt haben aber alles ganz gut im
Griff
es sieht alles danach aus dass die
Aussage die ich nicht aus der Hand
geschüttelt sondern sorgfältig beraten
deshalb auch mit großer innerer
Überzeugung gesagt habe dass wir ganz
gut aufgestellt sind auch unverändert so
gesagt werden kann wir haben
Konsequenzen gezogen aus den Erfahrungen
der letzten Finanzkrise 2829 und gerade
in Europa und in Deutschland sind sehr
viele sehr strenge Regeln
umgesetzt worden haben die
bankenlandschaften sich modernisiert
haben ihre Geschäftsmodelle profitabler
gemacht als sie vorher waren und sind
deshalb auch sehr stabil und man merkt
das jetzt ja auch an den Fällen die da
sind das sind ja
Fälle die vorwiegen dadurch eingetreten
sind das bestimmte handwerkliche Sachen
wie man als Bank das so richtig macht
nicht richtig gemacht worden sind im
Unterschied zu den USA haben wir nicht
nur sehr wenige Institute die der
strengen Regulierung der Zentralbank und
der Aufsichtsbehörden unterliegen
sondern so ziemlich fast alle also
das
ist in den USA so gemacht worden dass
dann auch so eine große Bank wie die
Silicon Valley Bank praktisch keinen
verschärftes Kontrollregime hatte und
das ist in Europa anders gelaufen und
wir können ganz froh sein dass wir das
gemacht haben denn das schafft uns jetzt
die Stabilität und begründet das
berechtigte vertrauen
so wir lassen noch zwei Fragen zu wir
müssen langsam zum Ende kommen
dr Bremer er soll sie haben gesagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren sie haben
aber Monate gezögert um denen die Hilfe
zu geben eigentlich die Kampfkraft zu
haben die sie brauchen womit haben womit
argumentieren sie das die sind heute in
der schwierigen Lage weil wir nicht
geliefert haben sondern weil sie bedacht
die Dinge wie sie sagen abgewogen
gehandhabt haben
ja und ich werde es auch weiter so
machen weil ich glaube dass das der
einzige Weg ist wie wir in dieser
schwierigen Situation agieren können wir
sollten keine allein Gänge machen
wir sollten alles abstimmen mit unserem
besten Freunden und Verbündeten
insbesondere mit den USA und da wir ja
zu den zählen die die wirksamsten Waffen
geliefert haben anders als manche die
viel Tönen und nicht so wirksame Waffen
geliefert haben es ist so dass wir
natürlich guten Grund haben dass auch
jeweils abzustimmen als wir mehrfach
Raketenwerfer geliefert haben habe ich
das zusammen mit
Großbritannien und den USA gemacht und
das war denen auch ganz recht dass sie
da nicht alleine sind wenn ich das mal
so vermuten darf und das kann ich auch
für viele andere Entscheidungen sagen
einschließlich der letzten die Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern betreffend das war mir
schon wichtig dass wir da nicht alleine
marschieren und ich bin sehr froh dass
die USA und wir da gemeinsam uns zu
entschlossen haben jeweils jeder für
sich aber das ist trotzdem gut gewesen
denn nachdem ich das gesagt hatte hat
sich herausgestellt dass manche von
denen man hier jeden Tag lesen und in
jedem Fernsehsender und Radiosender was
hören konnte und anschauen konnte dann
hinterher praktisch gar nichts gemacht
haben oder ziemlich wenig insofern heißt
das auch dass wir unser Rolle nur dann
gerecht werden wenn wir eben in dieser
Weise agieren und das bleibt und wird
die große Herausforderung bleiben die
Ukraine maximal zu unterstützen
und gleichzeitig alles dafür zu tun dass
eine Eskalation des Krieges zu einem
Krieg zwischen Russland und der NATO
vermieden wird und diese Aufgabe kann
man im Kamm Lehrbuch beantwortet finden
kann man nicht irgendeinem Computer zur
Lösung geben auch Chat gbt hilft da
nicht weiter das muss man wirklich
selber machen in enger Absprache mit all
den anderen die genauso wissen wie
gefährlich die Situation ist und dass
wir sehr klug entscheiden müssen
übrigens gehört zu der Frage wie kann
man dazu beitragen dass die Dinge
nicht schlimm eskalieren auch dass ich
nach China gefahren bin und mit dem
chinesischen Präsidenten gesprochen habe
was jetzt ja alle anderen auch in großer
Menge machen
aber es war doch etwas sehr Wichtiges
dass der chinesische Präsident gleich
laut und mit mir erklärt hat dass
Atomwaffen in diesem Krieg nicht
eingesetzt werden sollen wir kurz danach
das in Bali noch mal festgehalten haben
seitdem spielt das eine andere Rolle in
der Rhetorik Russlands auch wenn die
dann immer wieder mal zeigen dass sie
viele Atomwaffen haben wie gerade jüngst
ist das doch so dass das eine
Veränderung mit sich gebracht hat und
dieses Vorgehen das halte ich für
richtig verantwortbar und ich glaube die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
haben einen Anspruch dass wir das so
machen
[Applaus]
Frieda Gerber mein Name Herr
Bundeskanzler herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Ausführungen
meinerseits zum Schluss noch eine
ethische Frage ist steht im Raum dass
der Paragraph 218 abgeschafft werden
soll und er würde mich Ihre persönliche
Meinung dazu interessieren
ja ich bin der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wir haben
beschlossen dass alles eine so
schwierige ethische Frage ist wie man
mit der gesamten Gesetzgebung umgeht wir
dazu eine ExpertInnen bitten uns zu
beraten die nimmt jetzt gerade ihre
Arbeit auf und das wird eine schwierige
Frage sein wird mehrfach des
Bundesverfassungsgericht bewegt sie hat
mehrfach den Gesetzgeber bewegt alle
Parteien haben dazu Meinungen die sie in
ihre Wahlprogramme geschrieben haben und
deshalb glaube ich ist dass das
angemessene umgehen mit dieser Sache ich
bin froh dass wir jetzt sichergestellt
haben dass es niemand belangt wird weil
im vorgehalten wird er würde oder sie
würde werben für Abtreibung wenn man
einfach seine Dienste als Ärzte
sichtbar macht das ist ein guter
Fortschritt und diese Aufgabe haben wir
uns aber gemeinsam als so schwer
vorgestellt dass wir gesagt haben
einer Frage die so viel
gesellschaftliche Emotionen bewegt ist
es besser dass wir den Weg gehen
Herr Bundeskanzler wenn ich Harald
Schmidt wäre würde ich jetzt vielleicht
sagen wo bleibt denn bloß der Schmidt
wir können auch hier nicht ewig das
Vorprogramm machen da ich aber nicht
Harald Schmidt bin kann ich Ihnen nur
danken dass sie uns dass wir überhaupt
hier waren in einer so hektischen Woche
dass Sie uns so lange auch weit über die
geplante Zeit hinaus zur Verfügung
standen und Fragen ja aus allen
Lebensbereichen beantwortet haben und
sich auch nicht scheuten unmittelbar
nach Schmidt auf die Bühne zu gehen
von dem weiß ich dass das Kanzleramt
früher also vor ihrer Zeit größten Wert
darauf legt dass wenn die Kanzlerin und
Schmidt auf einer Veranstaltung
auftreten ein möglichst großer
Zwischenraum
eingeplant wurde man merkt sie sind
furchtlos sie haben sie ja nicht davor
sich heute noch nicht davor zurück
unmittelbar nach Schmidt auf die Bühne
zu gehen auch dafür herzlichen Dank aber
noch mal vielen Dank für ihren Besuchen
schönen Abend
also
danke schön danke schön
vielen Dank alles Gute gute Reise
[Applaus]